was once one of the most powerful men in
Hollywood now Harvey Weinstein will be
heading to prison that disgraced
Hollywood mobile found guilty today of
third-degree rape and a criminal sex
crime but the jury acquitted him on the
most serious charges being a sexual
predator which could have carried a
potential life sentence Weinstein faces
up to 29 years in prison before we get
to the facts of this though I just think
that I thought to myself today without
Ronan Farrow yeah would this have would
we have this day well what was Jodi
Cantor and Megan - he's the two
reporters at the New York Times who
originally broke that story and they
wrote the book she said where they go
into great detail but continued well not
me my point was NBC was sitting on this
on the Ronan Farrow stuff right yes so
and then Weinstein tried to prevent
Ronan Farrow front from try to get NBC
to stop it and then when Ronan continued
to work on it he did all sorts of things
like try to have him followed some
pretty nasty things and so yeah Ronan
Farrow though today tweeted that he
doesn't deserve any credit as you
pointed out the New York Times reporters
were there but he also said like the
women that came forward to tell their
stories were quite courageous he's gonna
him they asked for our home detention
for him because he had the surge back
stories that it didn't go well well it's
not gonna happen
looks like it's not gonna happen he's
got to go to Rikers he still faces cases
indictments in California and even if he
were to make a plea deal now on those
that the jail that he time that would do
here that would be that Californian time
would be in addition to he's he's facing
five to twenty nine years on these
convictions he was acquitted on the the
larger charges which included the
uncharged sexual abuse allegations so
this because I watched Dana's show Danny
McCarthy was on he said this is more
these convictions are more likely to
stand up under appeal because those
larger charges he was acquitted on but I
just want to point out one thing I hope
that these reporters everyone keeps
digging into the circle of people around
Harvey Weinstein throughout Hollywood
throughout politics who covered this up
literally for decades he was able to get
away with it because people either knew
and helped him basically destroy women's
lives and helped
continue to sexually assault women year
after year after year or that they just
looked away because he was benefiting
their careers where he was benefiting
their pocketbooks and that includes a
lot of Democrats so Jessie again you
know this is all new to us because it
just happened today folks but 25 years
what that's about not 29 yeah but okay
so five to 29 and the thought to my mind
was boy you know if he had been
convicted on that predatory sex charge
he would have gotten life now people are
saying he's gonna die in jail he's an
elderly man but in some ways he might
actually gotten off light well as Dana
said he stills facing charges in Los
Angeles I don't think this is light
I think they secured it in whatever
conviction they could get you know these
prosecutors we knock prosecutors a lot
especially from New York on this show
these prosecutors did a really good job
up against a very highly paid talented
criminal defense team that Weinstein
hired and you know he was dangling a lot
of cash in front of the victims and
trying to pay people off and having
people followed so credit to them you
know the me to movement you get a lot of
problems they're fake allegations no one
really knows what's going on but this is
where these things should be settled in
the court of law you have due process
you have people testifying you have
evidence and then a jury they decide if
there's criminal misconduct and how long
they should serve it I think that's the
most important thing here and I think
he's been convicted Greg so now yeah hey
a court of law he's a rapist right
that's a shame Hillary didn't win cuz
she could pardon him oh you know and I
and that's a joke but it's not a joke
because why was he so powerful he used
the women's movement and he used
empowerment as the liberal virtue
signals as a way to protect protect his
own credit predations right people knew
people joked about it but because he
helped the the Hollywood The Hollywood
issues for example I mean what did he do
he I mean like he actually accused in
2016 of Bernie Sanders of being a sexist
on Morning Joe to help out Hillary there
Michelle Obama praised him because he
gave so much money but so no one in
Halle
would can ever lecture us again about
morality because to your point they knew
all of this but he you know touched he
poked all the right buttons all the
virtue signals I think that's what
powerful people do they get away with a
lot of nonsense yeah all right another
big crime story following today jesse
Smollett back in court the actor
pleading not guilty to a new set of
charges that he lied to police about
being attacked by Trump supporters in an
alleged hate crime now I hate smashing
these two together I know they're both
antitrump people but or it could be I
don't know they're both also one Gomes
connected by a jury and one is under
indictment for lying
yeah lying to police is not the same as
rape of course not but but you know what
okay what keeps them together is they
both portrayed themselves as champions
of the aggrieved you can look at all the
people that are falling apart right now
Jesse did it for the fame right I'm a
victim avenatti did it for the attention
right he's going to help the downtrodden
Weinstein you know blogged on to these
onto these issues they all kind of are
in the same universe or pretending to be
for the common man or the common woman
so they could take advantage of the
situation they need to make an example
you can't lie the police and if you're
famous you better look out because look
at Martha Stewart she went to jail for
five months just for me for obstruction
of justice and lying to the FBI process
crime it may be but boom away you go
yeah I mean I well we can start talking
about you know some of those other
people like well he pled guilty okay so
there's that but on under Flynn's case
but with Smollett the Chicago Mayor Lori
Lightfoot she's the one who said he
needs to face the charges he committed a
crime needs to be prosecuted needs to be
held accountable and now it's really
better nicer this is for Kim Fox who was
the state's attorney there and at Cook
County she's being questioned like how
did you let this happen you did this
special deal and you do this thing and
that we have this big mess and it's very
convenient because now she says well now
that he's been charged I can't comment
because it's under yeah in fact she says
she should have done differently or
better but the election is in a few days
so we'll see how that plays out